all right folks today we're going to
continue answering the question that was
asked by aki are mutations really random
or something else going on here
this question is really cool to ask
because there's a large spectrum of
thought on this with inside the
scientific community and outside the
scientific community
one of the things that a lot of people
assume when they first learn about
evolution is that mutations must be
maximally random you'll hear people say
that there's random mutations and then
there's natural selection well that must
mean the mutations are maximally
random another thought is that random
mutations are naturally biased due to
physical constraints dna is a physical
structure
it lives in a physical world the cell is
a physical structure
so right here i have some computer tape
from an old computer an old russian
computer
computer computers used to store
information on tape like this
and so these dots
the dots and non-dots the holes and
non-holes that is data stored in this
piece of paper and what you can see here
is that because this is a physical
data storage some sequences of data
are more physically strong than other
sequences of data you know sometimes
there's lots of holes sometimes there's
not so many holes so if i were to pull
on this really hard it's going to break
according to the data that's actually
encoded in this piece of tape and a
similar thing happens
with dna and many biologists have
pointed out there are actual sequences
of dna that are more stable than other
sequences of dna and less stable and so
on
that's going to cause biases
in mutation rates across a stretch of
dna
and there's a bunch of other
physical constraints
that affect
mutations some people have built on top
of that argument and they say that you
know genomes could evolve to exploit
these natural mutation biases and then
optimize the process of evolution that's
a claim that's been debated quite a bit
within science and then finally you have
people outside of science saying that
mutations are willed into existence by
the power of the mind
and there are a couple of scientists who
have who've claimed things like this
uh rupert
i can't remember the name of the guy
there's a there's a guy who's
in england and he did plant genetics and
he he makes this claim he's got this
kind of a woo-woo
uh genetics that he teaches
as you can tell by the tone of my voice
i don't really take that stuff
incredibly seriously but it would be
worth doing a full video where i do take
it seriously at least for that one video
and we analyze
is there a grain of truth in this at
least
but today we're going to ignore that
noise we're going to focus
on the first claim here that mutations
are maximally
random we will also touch on these other
two mutations are naturally biased due
to physical constraints and then the
idea that natural selection could
actually play with this and we could get
what richard dawkins calls
the evolution of evolvability so back in
the 80s richard dawkins wrote this paper
where he claimed that
over evolutionary time the process of
evolution can actually get more
efficient natural selection can drive
the process of evolution to greater and
greater efficiency the evolution of
evolvability this new paper in nature
confirms richard dawkins suspicions
here they claim that this plant actually
has a little bit of control over how
random its mutations are our mission
today
is to first ask what would maximally
random mutations be like then we're
going to compare that to what mutations
are really like
and then finally and this will actually
be for next week next week's video
what exactly is it that's been recently
discovered and published in that nature
journal so what is a random process
i know that if i don't talk about this
a bunch of people in the comment section
a bunch of
philosophy bros with greek statues for
their profile pictures they're going to
be complaining they're going to say
things like the rolling of a dice isn't
really random it's predetermined
everything is determined the rolling of
a die is determined by slight movements
of the wrist slight imperfections in the
weight of each die and so on yes i know
i know
that a diet isn't purely random in a
theoretical sense but when the rest of
us talk about randomness we're talking
about that which cannot be confidently
predicted
and because this process or this outcome
cannot be confidently predicted we have
to use probabilities in order to make
any sort of prediction at all again that
doesn't mean that if we had perfect
knowledge of everything in the universe
that we couldn't predict that
probably we could but we don't have
infinite information about the universe
and so there's lots of things that are
random to us
they cannot be confidently predicted
when scientists talk about random
mutations they're usually talking about
a change in genome sequence so a change
in the dna sequence or an rna sequence
in an organism with an rna genome some
viruses have rna genomes so any change
in a genome sequence that the host
organism did not actively cause
and that has consequences the host
organism
didn't really predict now of course
organisms don't really predict what
mutations are going to do but over
evolutionary time you can get the
evolution of enzymes that
behave in a specific way because in the
past behaving that way worked and you
could say that that's a prediction right
the type of prediction in quotes random
mutations are in contrast to controlled
mutations
so a controlled mutation would be a
change in genome sequence that a host
organism actively caused because similar
changes were helpful in the past and
there's examples of all these so a
random mutation would be
uv radiation destroys a short segment of
dna
then repair enzymes patch that break but
the original sequence is not properly
restored
so the end result is a random sequence
change
then you have controlled mutations
bacteria use crispr enzymes to insert
short viral sequences into their own
chromosomes
those sequences will be used to fight
against the future invaders future virus
attacks
and then there's a bunch of different
things that we see the abilities that
organisms have to manipulate their own
genomes that you can call partial
control
so bacterial enzymes recognize and then
randomly scramble
sequences of dna that have been
dangerous in the past there's a really
cool paper called the genome strikes
back that outlines a bunch of these
evolved systems that can do this
kind of another way to think of this is
that random mutations are things that
happen because
the world is chaotic
the environment that cells live in it's
a chaotic environment the internal
environment of the cell where the dna
lives that's a chaotic environment
happens right
the controlled and the partially
controlled mutations
those are the result of evolved
systems evolved enzymes that can
actually actively induce mutations but
even still are these random mutations
maximally random so even even when when
nothing has evolved to help control them
are they maximally random what would
maximally random look like
there are lots of different types of
mutations you've got substitutions
insertions deletions and so on
to keep things simple here we're just
going to look at substitution mutations
and we're going to look at point
mutations point substitution mutations
so just a single nucleotide is
substituted for a different single
nucleotide to keep things
simpler still
let's just look at a cartoon version of
dna
and then let's just look at half
of that strand of dna keep things really
simple here we'll label it
now the expectation if mutations were
maximally random would be that all
substitutions are equally
likely
i'm showing that here this is what it
would look like
if all mutations
all substitutions were equally likely
but in reality this is not how things
actually work in reality
transition mutations are more common
than transversion
mutations you might have noticed that in
my my little cartoon drawing here
t's
and c's are just physically smaller than
a's and g's are and that's not just
that's not just an accident and how i
drew this that's actually real in real
life that's the case
a's and g's are larger nucleotides than
c's and t's are
and a transition mutation is when a
similarly sized nucleotide gets swapped
out for a different nucleotide of the
same size
so when an a is swapped out for a g
that's a transition mutation when a c is
swapped out for a t that's a transition
mutation
if an a were is swapped out with a
smaller c
that is called a transversion mutation
and it turns out that transversion
mutations are really rare
this is a physical
bias
it's easier for nucleotides that are the
same size to get swapped out for each
other it's just physically easier
the other thing that we would expect if
mutations truly were maximally
random
as we would expect that the mutation
rate
affecting a genome would be completely
random no rhyme or reason to it in
reality what we see is that
mutation rates increase
when cells are stressed
and decrease when cells are not stressed
this is really interesting and has
caused a huge debate early on a lot of
people thought that maybe
every time we see this what we're seeing
is we're seeing an evolved ability here
so if a cell is stressed out that must
mean that the cell is not fit for its
environment so it would make sense if
that cell decided oh i should evolve
faster now and it would increase its
mutation rate so a lot of people thought
that every time we see this we're seeing
that oh these cell is trying to control
its own evolution well to assume that
that's always what's happening here is
obviously pretty silly because
when cells are stressed out they simply
can't perform well at anything including
maintaining their own dna and so when a
cell is stressed out of course its
mutation rate is going to increase
because it's not good at doing stuff if
a cell is starved if it's not getting
proper nutrients
well it can't maintain its genome
properly it can't do the things that it
needs to do to keep its dna safe so duh
it's its mutation rate is going to
increase but because this
phenomenon naturally exists
of course it is possible
that natural selection could enhance
this
and you actually could get cells that
actively induce mutations
when they're not doing well they
actively induce mutations because in the
past doing this
made it so that they could
sometimes achieve mutational rescue this
would be an example of the evolution of
evolvability
that said it is pretty dumb to assume
that every time we see this
we're seeing a evolved response in
action
the third thing that we would expect to
be true if mutations were maximally
random
we would expect that mutations are
equally likely anywhere in an organism's
genome but alas
this is not the case
there are mutational hot spots and
mutational
cool spots
and again this just has to do with the
fact that dna is a physical thing living
in a physical environment the cell is a
physical environment it's a chaotic
environment certain stretches of dna are
going to be safer than other stretches
of dna just because of the way that
they're packaged inside of the cell i
think a lot about the the penguins
that are
huddled together in the middle of winter
trying to survive the penguins in the
middle deep in the middle they're safe
they've got all these penguins around
them the penguins on the outside they're
they're in trouble
and the same is happening in your genome
there are sections of the genome that
are just more exposed to danger than
other sections of the genome right this
is just inevitable this is an inevitable
consequence of being a physical thing in
the physical world the question is
has
natural selection exploited this fact is
there a way
in which genes that are really important
could end up over evolutionary time
residing in really secure areas of the
genome while
genes or just
random stretches of dna that are not
very important would end up taking up
the more dangerous areas of the genome
are there
like kings and ponds
within the genome it turns out that
there are mechanisms that could cause
this to happen
there are certain types of mutations
called translocations and trans
positions that will shuffle
where things are located in the genome
where certain stretches of dna reside
because those mutations are constantly
happening if you had strong enough
selection pressures you could get
natural selection to favor individuals
that have their most important genes
located in their most secure spots in
our last video we learned about
essential genes if you didn't watch that
you should go watch that after this one
because it's it's very important the
concepts that we we covered there
there are certain genes that are really
really essential i mean if you mutate
them even just a little bit
the organism can die or the cell can die
it would make a lot of sense for those
genes to reside in the safest possible
spots of the cell
so could this happen over evolutionary
time
the work of richard dawkins would
suggest that yeah that's certainly
possible other people are saying this is
definitely possible and might actually
be happening even in the human genome
here's a paper about that published back
in 2004
and then finally next week we're going
to dive deep into that new nature paper
saying that mutations aren't as random
as we thought
but today i just want to recap what
we've learned here so far so are
mutations really random by default
mutations are random
they're random and that they're not
confidently predictable but
they are naturally biased due to
physical constraints and because of
these natural biases natural selection
could harness these biases to optimize
the process of evolution that's
hypothetically possible
this would result in the evolution of
controlled mutations the evolution
of
evolvability so
make sure you're subscribed because next
week we're going to look at that new
paper and see
has this actually taken place
has
evolvability evolved within the plant
arabidopsis thaliana
you